I don't accept his apology I think he's
only apologizing because of people
coming for him and people or disagreeing
with them and he understands the basis
in Louise in there's a lot of black
people so I know whatever happens to mr.
nice to make 25 mil a year and have that
standard Malik Jackson he goes offensive
lineman pulling no punches regarding the
position on drew brees now look Malik
Jackson wasn't part of the team meeting
on Thursday where Drew Brees personally
apologized teammates he said enough to
get the teammates to go along with them
and I think the reality is if you're a
member of the Saints organization you're
looking for a reason to give him the
benefit of the doubt because ultimately
everybody's got to be on the same page
they got football games to play and it
looks like they've whipped up a little
of that us against the world mentality
Shaq supposedly told them last Thursday
don't let the media tear you apart as if
the media was the reason why they were
being torn apart they had teammates
going straight to social media to
complain about the guy and that was the
right to do it but I think that from the
standpoint of rallying the troops and
circling the wagons the bottom line is
the Saints have gotten on the same page
and I would expect that if anyone is
gonna have a problem with Drew Brees
going forward it's gonna be somebody
from a team that plays the Saints
because there isn't that extra incentive
to try to work it out and you don't know
the guy personally like teammates do
Chris that's that's the big thing you're
gonna be more forgiving when you're on
his team because you get to see the guy
on a day-to-day basis and realize that
you know he's not a jerk he cares about
people now I know Malik Jackson really
well he's my brother's college roommate
he's a great guy he really is and I
don't think you know his sentiments are
you know only to himself here I think
this is a very real thing I think a lot
of people you know around the league and
players are gonna look at Drew Brees and
go no he already showed or he already
exposed his true self and I don't think
you're gonna get a faction of guys off
of that they believe they already saw
the true colors of Drew Brees what I
would tell my friend Malik Jackson is
hey it took a lot of courage for Drew
Brees to say he was wrong he's you know
adamantly come out confronted the
president about the issue
I think he's self-evaluate
sell his life his wife which to me that
just tells you if it's hitting home the
wife comes out and makes a statement to
say you know we are the problem
I think this hit home to where it really
might have changed drew brees so I
understand what Malik Jackson saying
he's not gonna hurt him or try to do
anything like that when they play Malik
a good guy it's not about that but yeah
I think he's one of many in football
they're gonna look at Drew Brees and go
no we already saw the true guy this is
his true self and they're not gonna take
to the apology I had a moment there real
quick and we got to get to break where
I'm thinking if they have fans in
stadiums this year Drew Brees in
opposing stadiums may get a reception
unlike any he's ever gotten before from
some of the folks there depending upon
you know by the time we get to September
October November people are still aware
of it I think they will be and I think
that that maybe he should be thinking
hey this whole no fans in the stands may
not be so bad after all
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports